[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what is making the headlines with
the political editor of the liverpool
echo liam thorpe and anita botan former
conservative special adviser and
broadcaster they're going to be with us
from now until just before midnight
welcome to you both and thank you both
very much for joining us
so let's see what is on the front of
some of those front pages the murder of
nine-year-old olivia pratt corbell is of
course the lead for the liverpool echo
once again it shows her with two of her
best friends and a message from the
community we stand together
the metro goes with this promise from
the murdered girls family we will get
justice for our live
the sun reports that the only man
arrested so far in connection with the
killing is refusing to help police their
headline for the sake of little olivia
talk
the telegraph has comments about the
cost of the war in ukraine from
boris johnson's visit to the country
where paying higher bills ukraine is
paying in blood
that story is also the lead in the daily
express
on the subject of energy bills the
mirror carries this message from the
people of britain frees our bills now
the financial times leads with the
energy cost crisis and its effect on
businesses as they face a four-fold
increase in bills this autumn
back in ukraine the guardian leads with
a warning of a
catastrophe at the zaparisian nuclear
power plants because of russia's plan to
disconnect it from the national power
grid which experts say could damage its
cooling system
the eye claims an exclusive with news of
money troubles in the labour party
kirstama apparently telling his shadow
cabinet to stop fundraising for their
own officers to combat what it calls
labour's cash woes
whilst the times reports on alarm in the
nhs over liz truss's plan if she becomes
prime minister to divert 10 billion
pounds a year into social care
the mail has news of a new plan by the
home secretary to send illegal migrants
from albania back to albania
and after the heat wave the star has
news of storms to come with the headline
a hard rain's going to fall
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code that you can see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch with us and as we've said we've
been joined tonight by the political
editor of the liverpool echo liam thorpe
and anita botan broadcaster and former
conservative special adviser and liam
let's turn to you first and liverpool
echo it has of course been the still the
lead story uh exactly two days after
this happened um
this poor girl who's lost her life and
her poor family um
an easy you know lead for you a very
obvious lead what has the public
reaction been like there uh in liverpool
i mean we sense the shock and horror but
but but what is the feeling
yeah i think people are still shell
shocked that i spent some time in in the
community um
close to where this horrendous event
happened today and people are still they
still seem shell-shocked they still seem
to be trying to get their head around
the reality of this you know i spoke to
people who who live nearby who still
haven't found the words to explain to
their young children what's happened to
olivia because how do you even how do
you even start to to explain that to a
young child that another young child has
been has been shot dead inside her own
home and what we're trying to do with
this front page really is is show that
you know the vast vast majority of the
city of liverpool is is united in grief
for olivia in anger at what's happened
to her and in its demand that people do
come forward you know that obviously we
are still looking for this this palace
this cold-blooded killer who
was prepared to fire guns into a family
home prepared to leave a nine-year-old
girl dying as they ran away this there
have obviously been some movement to the
case today but the crucial thing here is
is finding the person who who shot this
young girl and bringing them to justice
and we've we've brought together a whole
range of people from across the city
footballers jamie carragher former
everton player peter reed politicians
counsellors and other celebrities who
are all speaking with one voice now and
saying
love any any kind of misguided sense of
of loyalty between criminals needs to go
and this is this is this crosses every
single line that you could ever imagine
and people need to to drop whatever
those kind of pretences are and and come
forward and get justice for this little
girl and her family who have gone
through something just unimaginable
absolutely um uh and anita if we look
move on to the metro we will get justice
for our live it is their headline
and liam touched on it you know this
this idea there's a great deal of
pressure on anybody who knows anything
about this to come forward the problem
is for the authorities isn't it that
people are scared to come forward people
are scared of repercussions if they do
come forward
yes and we can see from the details that
we do know about this incident and
obviously the use of guns um that you
know there are some suspicions that this
is um you know to do with some kind of
gang conflict or perhaps to do with
drugs um you know these this is a very
serious um and devastating crime for the
family um but we'll have huge
repercussions across the community and i
can understand um you know why people
may be hesitant to come forward but as a
community it feels as though you know
liverpool is reeling and um you know
some people coming forward will send a
really important signal of support i
think to the whole family and provide
that kind of reassurance that the report
is safe i mean this is such a senseless
um and deeply wounding and shocking
crime that and and you know with the
victim being you know a nine-year-old
girl in her own home um that
that that i'm hoping and we're all
hoping that with that community support
and with the activity of the police that
there are people that do come forward in
order to ensure that the person
responsible is held fully accountable
you've been down there as you say in the
community um the police have said that
they have had names given to them from
two different sources have people
contacted the paper to say
we know who this is
um
people do contact us
very regularly um with information on
this particular incident i think people
are scared and people i spoke to today
down at a community center right next to
where this happened they have been
providing an absolutely crucial resource
because they are encouraging people to
come forward to them
and to tell that to tell them you know
if they are scared or perhaps some in
some cases they don't want to speak to
the police for whatever reason they're
speaking to these local community
figures who are then passing that
information on to the police they i
heard today
from some of these community figures
that normally when when there are
incidents or or other crimes that the
the what's up groups and social media
are kind of alive with chat but this
time that on online there has been a
kind of wall of silence because nobody
people are scared and they don't want to
put their name to something or what they
are in it you know it's able to do
instead is pass it on to through this
community center which also has a an
anonymous uh tip-off box in there as
well and that is where police are
getting absolutely vital information and
we were able to corroborate that that's
that line today that the same game had
been have been mentioned several times
to these community figures and
councillors that's been past police and
you know that could be that could be the
thing that unlocks this case and that
that tracks this person down and begins
the process of getting justice for
olivia so vital work being done on the
ground by community figures
um let's move on from the front front
page of the liverpool echo to the front
page of the daily mirror uh and slight
similarities between these two front
pages actually and unusually um the echo
has got the the composite images of
people's faces at the bottom the mirror
too has but on a totally different story
which is quite unusual to see such
similar images on on papers on different
stories on the same day
anita this is about freezing our energy
bills we're going to get a figure aren't
we this friday about what the the next
price cap is going to be on this it's a
real worry though for people isn't it as
winter approaches
absolutely so this is the announcement
of the price cap that's going to start
in october so um i'm sure most people
watching us are aware but it's currently
1
971 pounds
and there have been some very stark um
predictions from experts about how high
his price cap could rise um you know one
fairly renowned um cornwall insights
institute put it at over 4 000 pounds so
tomorrow really is a very dramatic day
for those um for households as we
finally find out exactly how high the
price cap could rise by october um and
the mirror is you know tends to be labor
supporting is supporting labour's
proposal of essentially having the
government attempt to pay the entire
thing in order to absorb the um the cost
and the households will go over the
average cost um so
i mean it's there are no good solutions
i've got to say i'm pretty skeptical
about the numbers that labour have put
forward about how um this would be
affordable um but nevertheless i think
there's a really really tough autumn
coming and the one thing i think that
this plan around price freezes for
households doesn't address which is the
commercial cost there are so many
stories of for instance chip shops and
small businesses that simply cannot
fathom being able to stay afloat and
without additional support not to
mention
public services which brings us on very
neatly to the financial times at liam
and that is its front page the cost of
doing business crisis looming as company
fuel bills rise four-fold and i suppose
a lot of people will say oh well i'm not
worried about what what big companies
have to pay for their energy bills but
as anita points out it's it's it's your
local chip shop isn't it it's
it's lots of of smaller companies and
even the big ones if they go out of
business what about the people who work
for them what about their jobs
yeah we've got the federal small
businesses quoted saying you know urgent
government intervention is needed right
now and i think right you know the big
the big companies the corporations
they'll they'll survive they'll they'll
take a hit but they'll survive it's your
it's your independent businesses your
your cafes your bars your restaurants
your chip shops you your your
independent shops that you know we could
see a a huge number of these businesses
forced to close this winter and if
unless urgent help is needed um if you
look at the hospitality industry for
example which has suffered more than any
other really during the covered crisis
they were the first to shut shut the
longest we've seen um sasha lord who's
the great manchester night time economy
advisor talking about how those those
businesses that are just about trying to
recover are now the ones again that
could be here they're facing enormous
costs a lot of these businesses are due
to uh to renegotiate or restart new
contracts in october which just so
happens to be the exact time when when
you know this price cap goes up so it's
a hugely hugely worrying time and i just
feel like this this conservative um
leadership contest is is just going on
in a sort of parallel universe we've got
all these massive fears that are
happening you know we've got the price
cap going up on friday and and somehow
this this leadership contest is still
ongoing and we don't know what their
plans are we're here we've not heard
enough about what they're going to do
for so many worried people and
businesses and this half we're going to
kick off with a telegraph uh anita and
this boris johnson's surprise visit
today on independence day to ukraine
and he's he's made it very clear that
that we have to stay the course with
ukraine and that people back in the uk
may feel the pinch this winter they may
struggle to heat their homes but we must
stay the course um he says um we also
know if we're paying our energy bills
for the evils of vladimir putin the
people of ukraine are paying with their
blood
yes some some very strong words from the
prime minister today and i think um you
know striking that important tone of
defiance and making it clear i think
that the uk will always stand with
ukraine and it is worth saying um that
you know the the situation regardless of
essentially of our position and our
support for ukraine the the challenge
around energy prices would exist due to
this conflict in and of itself so the
resolve is really about the uk i'm
continuing to pledge its military
support for the ukraine because russia
is always going to in this climate try
to wage war with energy and so i think
that it's absolutely the right thing for
the prime minister to show the uk's
solidarity um in the face of what is
senseless and
egregious violence um and and you know
now we're talking about six months into
this invasion with the russia's offense
of appearing to peter out there's
possibly some sort of
moment of optimism in the midst of all
this um violence and death um in ukraine
um but i think it's it's really
important the prime minister in one of
his final acts once again reinforces the
uk solidarity and close relationship
with ukraine uh and liam as well as the
horror of of skyrocketing energy prices
the guardian's front page
is keeping an eye on zaparisia and this
nuclear plant and it's a it's an element
of the war that i just find absolutely
terrifying
if this plant is allowed to fall into
disrepair if the
energy isn't kept on at this plant the
implications as as a uh petro cotton
quoted there on the front of the
guardian are not just for ukraine but
for the whole world
that's the thing you know sometimes of
course
other news stories certainly in our in
my local area and can take over
proceedings and and that's very much the
case in this week for us particularly
but and you know it's six months now of
this conflict six months of this
invasion and of course it will
occasionally slide down the the the new
agenda as other things happen
domestically um but i think this is this
is a reminder this story about the
nuclear plant from the guardian that you
know we are all in you know we're all in
a very uh still remaining in a place of
real danger um when it comes to this
conflict the the story essentially is
that you know russia may try to
disconnect um zaparizia from the ukraine
power grid um which which you know would
be an extremely dangerous move it it
could connect disconnect the cooling
towers which keep things stable and you
know it's the biggest nuclear power
plant in in europe so you know we don't
have to be
particularly tuned into that type of
science to know just how dangerous that
could be we know what's happened
previously in chernobyl um so it's it's
it's a reminder isn't it to everyone
around europe